The success of our VQE algorithm heavily
depends on the state and circuit
we choose to begin with.
I'm Victoria Lipinska and in this video
we'll explore the options
we have in designing them.
Let's take a closer
look at all the elements
we have in every run of the quantum
part of the VQE.
We begin with the reference state,
sometimes called initial state.
We run the reference state
through a parameterized circuit called
a variational form
with an initial choice of parameters,
and we measure the state
in the basis of the Hamiltonian
after running it through the circuit
to obtain the expectation value. Now
we'll walk through each of these elements,
starting with the reference state.
A typical choice for the reference
state is the zero state.
That is the state in which a quantum
computer is already initialized.
For quantum chemistry problems,
one can also use the so-called
Hartree-Fock State,
which is the result of a Hartree-Fock
method.
In a nutshell, Hartree-Fock
theory gives a simple way to construct
the reference state by approximating
the ground state of a quantum system.
It finds a rotation
within the space of states
that minimizes the ground state energy.
Finally, the reference state
can also be very problem specific,
and you may want to choose
a custom state.
In the case when you know what properties
your system has, for example, symmetries
or a specific number of electrons
in the state, you can use that
to have better convergence of the VQE
algorithm.
Choosing a good reference
state is important for convergence
reference states that are close to
the ground state
can make the problem converge
much easier and faster.
Similarly important
is the choice of initial parameter values
that we feed into the variational form.
Therefore, depending on the reference
state and initial parameters,
we may converge quickly, slowly
or not converge at all.
Let's look at this plot
and for visualization purposes,
let's imagine that our space of parameters
has only one parameter.
A very good reference state
can allow you to start very close
to the final ground state
and then convergence will be fast.
On the other hand, if you start very far
from the ground state here,
reference state
a, you will have to cross a high energy
barrier leading to a very slow convergence
or no convergence at all.
We will discuss this in more depth
in the classical optimization module
in this course.
Let's now look at the parameter circuit
that acts on the reference state, a.k.a.
the variational form.
When this circuit, the know,
the U of theta acts on the reference
state,
it produces what we call a trial state
psi of theta or sometimes ansatz.
It is this ansatz state that is
then measured in an appropriate basis
to obtain expectation
value for the energy.
The variational forms
that we're discussing here